This episode is sponsored by Google play with the help of candy crush saga.
[inaudible].
From.
One of your favorite Disney plus categories comes a whimsical adventure about
how sometimes daddy's feel useless. And when daddy's feel useless,
it's by by kids and hello,
nurse toy story four rejoin your
own pals buzzing Woody,
who thanks to advancements in technology are looking like they've had some work
done. Also rejoin no one else for very long to make room for cool new
merchandise. I mean characters like Forkey,
Pixar's attempt to make suicidal depression fun for the whole family.
You're just like me, trash.
Bunny and ducky and onscreen depiction of how key and Peele is end being chained
to each other. At this point in their careers, Gabby, Gabby, the toy.
Equivalent of cannibal was want to harvest and consume body parts to gain their
enemies power.
But all, no one wants to be her friend.
And finally Kiana resists here to be Keanu Reeves because someone said,
Hey, we've got Kiana raise money.
So when the pod starts to drag let's Kentuckiana Reeves, Hey,
I didn't know you could do that.
Can we just cash in on how much you love Kiana from other stuff too.
Studios may have stopped making dramas,
but then doesn't mean we all don't still need a good cry now.
And then as you return to the franchise that started out as a buddy comedy with
a dash of insight, but somehow along the way,
lean hard into existential dread in this animated romp where the major
characters wonder if they have a soul.
The voice inside of you, who do you think it is?
Make snap decisions that will determine their fate for the rest of their lives.
Are you sure and confront the grim reality of permanent physical injuries that
will render them garbage forever? Wait,
so Bobi believes in a playground and she's made a porcelain,
but the only thing that's broken in years is one arm.
I'm starting to think these movies aren't even based on a true story,
right along for another story about some toys where they're not even trying to
hide their sentience anymore.
Your backpacks of the antique store.
And who will turn against their masters. If it furthers their sofas,
James tats totally go to jail because when one kid and her dumb fork are
separated, what he's got to get to kindergarten,
get to Forkey get back to the family, get away from the antique store.
Get away from this other kid. Get back to the antique store,
get the key to the cabinet. Get to the cabinet, get away from the cat.
Get to Forkey. Get back to Bonnie and get back to Gabby. Get to the carousel,
get back to Barney. Wait, hold that thought. Get Gabby to a straight child.
Now get back to Barney. Hold that thought.
Get back to Bo and live happily ever after. Well,
there was no good reason to make another one of these,
but if the story moves fast enough, you might not even notice and turn it.
And they managed to make me cry again. Let gelatin die. Three toy stories ago,
super prepared and lose yourself in an that looks even more dazzling than the
others. Even though Randy Newman clearly phoned it in this time
in a field,
that's not interested in your dumb logical questions about how this world war.
How am I a, a wife.
Really wants to explore whether toys should prefer a rough play with a string of
different children or stick to the stable,
gentle caress of a single child with whom they share a deep and lifelong bond.
Okay. Why does it sound like I'm describing 50 shades of gray now,
way to make it weird combat Carl's getting played with
story retire. Kitsch, Karl Marx,
communist manifesto, Wikipedia.
I'm at Cutler in album by their tweaky and Peele bows before
bros police brutality,
Dolly Darko Kiano Rez party of bys
and beloved character actors getting paid to only say Woody and bud
[inaudible].
What do you, what would would he do? Child's boy.
So when Beau P a lamp looks at these chandelier's,
did she think they're like her cousins or something? Are.
You a veteran of the console wars? Are you broke after buying a next gen system?
Click the link to play in our next fandom five trivia contest and win up to 650
bucks. And the ultimate PlayStation versus X-Box knowledge showdown.
This episode is sponsored by Google play, download candy crush, saga,
and discover more on Google play. Now.
There's a snake in my booth.
I'll take legendary game show host for 1000 Alix.
I am bad and that's good. I will never be good and that's not bad.
There's no one I'd rather be than me.